Hey friends, a visual politic. Before we start with today's video,
let me tell you about our brand new channel visual Academy.
We we're going to talk about one of the great strategists.
Here. We cover world history with high-end animations stories,
like the empire of Gangas can,
the life of Alexander the great and Zeus has many, many love affairs,
plus a bunch of others. Don't forget to check out. I'll leave you Alexa,
and the description box below where you can check out the amazing animations,
the cool stories,
and you might even recognize one of the voiceover guys check out a note.
The it.
The 25th of October, 2020 in the middle of the coronavirus pandemic,
Chileans were called to vote for the national plebiscite of 2020,
our referendum, the asset ISANS if they wanted a new constitution to be written.
And if so, who they wanted to do it,
the referendum was far from being run of the mill for two reasons.
On the one hand,
the future of the country was to be decided to such an extent that the
construction of a new Chilean Republic was at stake,
which would make it the sixth. And furthermore,
it would take place in the midst of a wave of unbridled violence. In fact,
a few days before the vote, we were seeing news headlines like this one.
Violent protests, resurgent Chile,
two weeks before the referendum for a new constitution as BICE,
October 19th,
2022 churches set on fire in Santiago that she laid after a journey of protests,
your own news.
And this is all not something recent or merely coincidental.
The situation that has been going on in jelly for more than a year now has
cleaned the lanes of at least 36 people and racked up almost 9,000 arrests so
far. There's no end in sight for these disturbances, of course,
and lay out the results of the constitutional referendum in which more than 78%
of the voters supported a new constitution.
It was seeing that the Chilean society seeks once and for all to turn the page
and re-establish social piece with a new Supreme charter.
So why did Chileans want a new constitution? What is wrong with the current one?
How does the constituent process work? And Chile,
is this really such a good time to launch, enter such a venture? Well,
my friends and this video,
we are going to answer all of these questions and a bunch of other ones.
So let's go.
Cracking.
There's. One thing that is undeniable is that under the term constitution,
Chile has achieved the highest standards of development and living standards in
all of Latin America. Remember,
this is a region where poverty continues to be widespread and where things,
at least in the short term, unfortunately do not look good.
So the dilemma here would be as the economy.
The only thing that matters well for seven to 8% of Chileans,
the answer seems to have been a clear and resenting. No,
the economy is not the only thing that matters. In fact,
the reasons for wanting a new constitution are very broad,
but we could summarize them in that the current constitution of 1980 was created
by a brutal dictatorship. And we conceived with an authoritarian objective.
One that is very different from the political model of days,
Chile so much so that even president Sebastian Panetta and his party have
supported the approval, the vote in favor of change and this latest referendum.
[Inaudible].
You see,
despite the fact that the current constitution has received 31 modification
since being launched in 1980 with two of them quite significant in 1989 and
2005, the truth is that the big dilemma seems to be an addition to parts of its
content,
the form by which it was approved and the political and social context in which
it was written. And although it's true that under this constitution,
the vast majority of governments have been center left among them eight headed
by the socialist Michelle battler and a more acceptable functioning of
democratic institutions as being guaranteed.
The problem with the old constitution is above all.
And the state structures underpins structures that favor stability,
but which make practically any substantial political reform, very complicated.
And these are reforms that would be fully accepted in other domains.
In fact.
The great political problems of Latin America is precisely this as a general
rule,
their constitution and laws have added social rights to their texts as protests
have occurred,
but they have made sure not to touch the many political privileges accommodated
for the elites were rigid elites that manage to stand fast generation after
generation, but let's not get sidetracked here.
The point is the oldest change that has been set in motion in Chile is
generating an enormous sea of doubts about what the new ultimate result of the
Chilean constitution may be. Of course, before getting into this question,
it's a good idea to take a look at the current one from 1980,
to understand why the Chileans don't like it anymore. So my friends,
the question is as this next constitutional change justified, well,
let's take a look.
[Inaudible].
The problems with the 1980 constitution.
If there is one thing that is controversial and disputed about the 1980
constitution,
which has created and promoted by the dictatorial murderous regime of Augusta
Pinochet is precisely it's legitimacy. Yes,
it is true in a way that their founding document was more or less legitimized
over time by way of a lot of modifications and the same way the Chilean
constitution has also been the legal cover of different democratic governments.
But the reality is that the context of this document has never stopped being
hurtful to many Chileans besides being controversial too. And in fact,
some experts and temporary the feeling of the Chileans towards their basic law,
towards their national charter in this way.
Like someone who owns a beautiful house,
but he does not want it anymore because it was built by a father who is a
rapist, does not a problem about the house itself.
The problem is that it was built by that father, Patricia Navea,
Latin American and Caribbean studies professor at New York university.
In addition, the main idealogue of the 1980 constitution politician jurist,
an academic Jaime Guzman designed it in a way that made it especially
complicated to undertake our reaching political reforms
Guzman's objectives were therefore,
if not to conserve the totality of Pinochet's political regime,
once there was a change to maintain the structures, the design,
the shell of the state, as it was in fact,
one of Jaime Guzman's best known quotes regarding the objective of as
institutional construction is this one.
The constitution must ensure that if adversaries come to govern,
they are constrained to follow an action,
not so different from the one that we would yearn for.
So that the range of alternatives that imposes on those in power are reduced
enough as to make it extremely difficult to do other things. Hi,
Megan is Mon ideologists, the Chilean constitution.
1980, sounds democratic, right?
Not exactly a good example of all of this can be found in article nine.
The article is exceptional when it's compared to other constitutions around the
world,
it talks specifically about terrorism and sets out a series of prohibitions.
Remember,
this is within the constitution itself for anyone who is declared a terrorist,
then it uses a reinforced majority law that determines under which assumptions
you are or are not declared a terrorist,
but that the danger of the article is not just that.
Let me explain,
look at some of the prohibitions established for these alleged terrorists.
Those responsible will be disqualified to exercise public functions or positions
for a period of 15 years,
whether or not they are popularly elected or as a director or director of an
educational establishment or to exercise teaching functions in them to exploit a
media or to be a director or administrator of it,
nor may they be leaders of political or education-related organizations or of a
neighborhood professional business union student,
or union character in general during said term article nine of the constitution
of Chile.
Now obviously no one here is in favor of terrorism nor of not condemning
terrorists. But the important question here is what is a terrorist?
Yes, well, that's exactly what the reinforced majority law sets out,
but the mere existence of that article is a window of opportunity for a
political majority. To determine that terrorism, for example,
is something very different from what we are all thinking terrorism actually is.
And of course the Pinochet regime had something very different in mind when they
wrote this article, if necessary,
this legal construction could be used by an authoritarian president to eliminate
from public life, not only the political opposition,
but also any dissident citizen depriving them of their public jobs of being
teachers or exercising freedom of the press. For example,
it is just one example of how this constitution is rooted in a very different
ideology than what we are used to seeing in more advanced democracies,
but actually thus far the worst aspect,
the power granted to the president is immense much greater than that,
of any other unitary republics with a presidential list system,
to give you an example,
article 65 of the current Chilean constitution attributes exclusively to the
president of the Republic to take the initiative and things like this.
Impose suppress reduce or forgive taxes of any kind or nature,
create new public services or state funded jobs to fix modify grant
or increase salaries, retirement, pensions, mutual aid subsidies,
and any other kind of emoluments establish the modalities and procedures of
collective bargaining establish or modify the rules on social security,
article 65 of the constitution of.
Exactly, as it says, only the president can take the initiative to, for example,
abolish attacks, raise it lower.
It create a new one or modify pensions or social security rules.
And what if the president doesn't want to, well,
it can't be done wherever the parliament says,
this has its benefits and also severe drought.
[Inaudible].
For example, some supporters of the structure,
including many libertarians argue that these exclusive initiatives are positive
and that they favor fiscal discipline as well as limit and avoid the political
electoral conflicts that could affect many legislators because in Chile,
presidents cannot run for consecutive reelection. However,
it seems that the political and social majority is not so clear.
And in any case,
there are greater powers than those usually granted to the presidents of the
most developed democracies,
because there's not a question of whether or not the president has a veto,
but rather that the entire initiative as exclusively has in any case,
what is clear beyond the political legal debate as, as we saw before.
But the 1980 constitution seems a clear reminiscence of another era where the
president and authoritarian one at that had all the power. Nevertheless,
what as a fact is that the Chileans are about to have a completely new
constitution and the process to achieve it will be carried out through what is
known as a constituent process. Now,
what is this process like and what are its limitations? Well, let's take a look.
The Chilean constituent process.
My friends are visual politic and Chile.
There are two types of organization that can draft a constitution.
Once of course,
the initiative to have a new constitutional text is approved by referendum.
We are talking about what is known as the joint convention and the
constitutional convention, which have some important differences. And in fact,
end those differences lies one of the greatest risks,
one of the greatest dangers that chili will soon face,
but we'll talk about that later.
The main difference between the Mex convention and the constitutional convention
is who elects its members.
In the case of the Mex convention is composed of 172 constituents.
Half of them are parliamentarians elected by Congress and the other half are
citizens elected by popular vote. And this case,
the famous rule of parity approved by law by both chambers of the national
Congress requires that there be half men and half women,
but this only applies to constituents who are citizens,
not the parliamentarians in contrast the constitutional convention as 155
members who are all citizens elected by popular vote and who must all be half
male and have female.
[Inaudible] yes, [inaudible].
The option that won the national referendum of October,
2020 was the constitutional convention.
So there'll be 155 citizens responsible for creating the new constitution.
As far as the operation of this constitutional convention goes,
which to all effects is a constituent assembly.
It will have strong limitations both in time and on its scope of action.
[Inaudible].
For example, once its members are elected and fully activated,
the convention will have only nine months extendable by three more to draft the
new text entirely from scratch and have it approved by a two thirds majority.
But that is,
they have a maximum of one year to draft and approve by a reinforced majority
each and every one of the articles, chapters,
and blocks of the new constitution. This is certainly a tight timeframe,
which as we will see a little later poses, a significant risk.
In addition,
the law establishes that the constitutional convention only dedicated itself to
drafting of the new constitution and other words,
it may not interfere in any other matter of the state nor supplant or
conditioned to legislative executive or judicial powers.
And of course it must be governed by the rules that are currently enforced.
In other words, for the evil minded,
there is no room for what happened in Venezuela where the constituent assembly
constituted in 2017 has since completely usurped to the powers of the national
assembly, becoming a parallel and undemocratic legislative body. In addition,
once the final text of the new constitution is agreed upon and voted on by two
thirds, citizens must endorse it. And what is known as an exit referendum,
which is basically a consultation for approval or rejection of the new
constitution.
Now don't start the parade just yet because despite the legal guarantees that
make the Chilean constitution process,
one of the cleanest and most advanced in Latin America,
the truth is that the risks of doing all this at precisely this point in time
are many, and here is the enormous dilemma that exists in this whole issue.
And my friends believe me, this is perhaps the most dangerous point, listen up.
Uh, high voltage, new constitution.
It is what it is.
If there was one thing that will notably frame the process of writing this new
constitutional text and Shelly right now is precisely it's social political and
no it's economic situation as well.
And the fact that the constitutional convention has been chosen as the method
for carrying out and even more risk to this delicate game.
Think about it for just one moment and the face of the outbreak of violence and
mobilizations.
And now also the economic and social crisis produced by the Corona virus.
The vote of the members of the constituent convention could be a real danger.
It's no secret that in times when societies are struggling are also times when
radical movements have the most opportunity to achieve broad levels of power.
And of course the most significant risk that arises from this whole scenario is
that Shalynn's with such a political situation and above all a social explosion
will elect a majority of constituents with very radical possessions,
perhaps very linked to what has become known in Latin America as 21st century.
Can you imagine that people who defended the regime of Venezuela or the policies
of the governments of Bolivia or Argentina, for example, may participate in,
or may have even brought this whole process on this is not a minor question.
Being the exception in Latin America to a constant succession of great
frustrations and broken dreams. Yes,
the country has many problems such as a broken social mobility elevator,
or a poorly implemented pension system,
but still these problems are a far cry from what is the norm at a regional level
where things are obviously much,
much worse at the regional level generally has been a model of success,
democracy and stability for the last three decades.
And the question we can ask ourselves as well,
the new constitution guarantee that the essence of what is known as the Chilean
model remains in place and be careful because it is very easy to promise all
kinds of rates, but then to enforce them well, that is not so easy anymore.
What's more,
the constant violence to which Chileans have had to become accustomed during the
last year could be used by the radicals as a method of pressure against the
citizens who are drafting the new constitution. On top of that,
the short tightened limit of one year will force the constituents to be very
quick and not to be each article too much.
If they want to have the full text approve on tape. In other words,
we run the risk of trying to heal a wound by pouring boiling hydrogen peroxide
on it. Something that is, of course not recommended a new constitution,
undoubtedly was necessary,
but was this the best point in time to get down to business.
[Inaudible].
And that is precisely why there is quite a lot of concern about what kind of
constitution may emerge from these conditions.
It certainly does not seem that the new constitution will be orientated to limit
the power of the state and its president as is the case with the United States,
for example,
but rather that it will end up being a text that gives the state enormous
powers, many responsibilities,
and a great deal of public intervention on a lot of issues concerning society
and the economy.
It's easy to see that one wants to resemble countries like Sweden or Norway,
but isn't there a danger that it will end up looking more like the Argentinian
model. All of this is not an easy process. The Scandinavian models demand a lot.
And I mean, a lot of competitiveness,
something that the Chilean economy does not have. So the risk is on the table,
but that said,
it's now over to you after understanding all the horrible things that chili went
through in the 1980s, do you think that Shelly does need a new constitution?
Do you think now is the right time to launch a new national charter?
And what would you put in one, if you've got to design one from the bottom up,
leave your answers in the comments below.
So we really hope you've enjoyed this video. Please hit, like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that we're not my dulcet tones. Also,
this channel is possible because of, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice, um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or
Google play, or your favorite pod catcher.
[inaudible].